the hot boy's my favorite movie I just
talked to Silk before
um I flew her how boys is your favorite
movie yeah in life yeah yeah how many
movies have you seen a million um and
Hot Boys starring silk the Shockers your
face hi boys like Silk man silk just got
through talking so no limit so like I
always say that Silk is the best worst
rapper ever the worst rapper no the best
the best worst rapper ever I must give
on that cause he ain't gonna lose me so
you see that movie poster over there
belly that is the best worst movie ever
why is it worse because it's really not
a good movie but it's great
I love that [__] movie that movie is
nostalgic that movie like reminds me of
a place in my childhood it's amazing I
wish Hype Williams would have kept
making movies
okay what about Richard that's right
it's not belly I like belly but
belly's the